che figata che mette a fuoco come vuole
2018 per trovare una webcam che mettesse
a fuoco subito c'è fantastico ragazzi
questo era comunque il mio uomo mi state
mandando fatto tutti quanti che lo stato
e trovando e video la risposta a tutti
quanti
no non è fei che il mio nuovo l'altro vi
lascio in descrizione il link di dove
trovarlo se ci avete un market vicino
casa che lo vende lo trovate nel link
qui sotto il vestito è oggi è uscito
anzi ne è uscito un po di tempo fa però
lo giochiamo oggi tra il face quest
videogames due appunto praticamente
ragazzi hanno fatto troppi spesino games
2 avevo fatto il primo se non sa con i
riferimenti ai videogiochi non mi
rompete se non mi viene in mente quale
videogioco in questione è un gatto checa
gas capisco e non riesce a cagare
stitico e guarda i video di pietro che
devo continuare a tappare
[Applauso]
io mi sono diplomato per questo capita
il problema andiamo avanti
c'è un tipo che fa le cose strane lo
dovevo scappare al volo scommette dunque
trophies questo è un gioco dove devi
fare dove devi fare cose che non ti
aspetti stavo dicendo esattamente quello
è infatti spuntato un cesso va bene poi
finirci dentro zio perfetto spesa vi
rappresenta un bene o tomb raider siamo
un po moderni adesso è anche uscito il
film e vediamo di cosa si tratta
devo saltare dall'altra parte fin qua
abbiamo capito cosa io sono la statua
c'è lara croft del mio nemico quindi
devo dirlo ma è ancora family friendly
il video così secondo me se hai fallito
lo stesso devono continuare a farle
crescere
beh è educativo questo gioco almeno
forse nessuno riesce a saltare
dall'altra parte però provaci
esatto stu della rosa ho visto perfetto
l'importante è andare avanti nei livelli
ragazzi facciamo poche storie
oddio chi l'editor che figata sto
pensando a da pietro quindi non hanno né
lui carta igienica non è lui una mosca
non è lui
adesso sì che ci sia più nove ragazzi
c'è un qualcosa che devo fare in questo
momento esatto lo sapevo lo sapevo io
devo fare la roma del jazz sapevo all
iter nightmares che figata
sì in questo caso dovessi scappare nel
gioco però sono caduto
quindi
si aspetta però la cacca dove dovrebbe
essere questo gta waster va bene secondo
me i ragazzi devo usare la palma come se
fosse un trampolino scommetti qualche
modo adesso non so come piano piano
piano potrebbe essere più difficile del
previsto insomma fermati a questo punto
il teatro e vice in tv
mica so io avrò giocato a partiti quelli
che sta ancora uno stupido ma va bene ma
farc c'è una ragione e col fatto che
dovevo usare la palma come trampolino va
bene
mio dio fa tra tutte le parodie di
questo quadro a sé paragoni floppy bird
proprio di flachi bird date farà tutto
per un attimo credevo di aver vinto ma
va bene che io che ho voluto su youtube
evitare in tutti i modi possibili fares
l'api bird per non rovinarmi l'anima lo
devo fare per forza adesso cioè
sostenuto honda
ripeto come se non si fosse capito
questo è il mio lavoro giocare la sta
roba kidman che faccio ma sei scemo
secolo sbagliato sei scemo sto facendo
c'è un codice a barre mitico dice
parametri codici a barre ok perfetto
abbiamo trovato la soluzione per i
bigliettini a scuola regata attuativi
sulla parte dietro il compagno che avete
davanti
le soluzioni non puoi dire stato a te
all'alunno quindi poi copiare
tranquillamente avanti va bene per il
etica next level il trend di cava de
tris è caduto un pezzo del tetris
se ti spostassi magari potrebbe solo
inizio per vincere livello 6 voglia e
per carità non va beh sicuramente devo
fare qualcosa col cremlino che ha fatto
benissimo tra l'altro devo fumare da
qualche parte ma no non volevo fare
questo ma ok va bene ci ha preso gusto
rega prefetto
[Musica]
meno domande ci facciamo e meglio è come
al solito ci mettono molto di più in
genere questo potrebbe essere un
problema
e giusto no vallini sono seconda ai
liberi io ho capito adesso ho vinto per
forza perfetto vabbè dai sta diventando
sempre più idiota sembra robot wars
domini ho vinto
ovviamente no però sarebbe stato bello
allora si devono scontrare sicuramente
potevo fare qualcos'altro non so cosa
tipo trascinare e perché il tipo è
contento anche a lui si sfascia da
macchina ma scusa per mac a deve cadere
qualcosa dall'alto scommetti sapevo
madonna madonna ma oramai ocevi giuro ho
talmente tanto la mente deviata che
riesco a finire i veri trophies quest
anche a lui perché dai qualcosa per un
calzino
veramente non ho idea di cosa di come
esprimermi in questo momento va bè
ragazzi io concludo qua per adesso il
primo episodio visto che ci sono altri
16 livelli
spero vi sia piaciuto ragazzi come me mi
piace anche a lei sa che viene ad una
descrizione tosatore si discute e noi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo video se la
faccio per bilanciare la cosa faccio il
test e del conseguente intellettivo
serviva almeno bilanciamo i due gameplay
perché questo era un po troppo troppo
poco da einstein come gioco però vabbè
da ragazzi
[Musica]